.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
THIS IS NOT GOOD NEWS FOR
DR. FLIP FLOP FAUCI.
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE COVID-19 ORIGINATED IN
THE LAB ACCORDING TO A NEW
CONVENTION OF STATES POLL.
ON MSNBC FAUCI GOT MAD AND
INDIGNANT AND TRIED TO CLAIM ANY
CRITICISM OF HIM IS A CRITICISM
OF SCIENCE.
NO, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S VERY DANGEROUS BECAUSE A
LOT OF WHAT YOU ARE SEEING AS
ATTACKS ON ME ARE ATTACKS ON
SCIENCE.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT I HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT CONSISTENTLY FROM
THE BEGINNING HAVE BEEN
FUNDAMENTALLY BASED ON SCIENCE.
SOMETIMES THOSE THINGS WERE
INCONVENIENT TRUTHS FOR PEOPLE
AND THERE WAS PUSH BACK AGAINST
ME.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO GET AT ME
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL AND
A SCIENTIST, YOU ARE ATTACKING
NOT ONLY DR. ANTHONY FAUCI YOU
ARE ATTACKING SCIENCE.
>> Sean: SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
ON.
JANUARY 31, 2020 DR. FAUCI GOT
AN EMAIL SUGGESTING THERE WAS
EVIDENCE OF THE GENOME WAS
TAMPERED WITH IN A LABORATORY
THAT ALTER THIS VIRUS.
DID WE FUND THIS WITH GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH?
I THINK THEY ARE VERY DAMNING.
>> EVERY TIME I I AM ASKED ABOUT
DR. FAUCI I SAY THE SAME THING.
I KNOW DR. FAUCI.
I LIKE DR. FAUCI.
I RESPECT DR. FAUCI.
BUT DR. FAUCI NEEDS TO CUT THE
CRAP.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DR. FAUCI.
IT'S NOT ABOUT HIS FEELINGS.
I AM SORRY IF HIS FEELINGS WERE
HURT.
MAYBE HE OUGHT TO BUY AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT PONY.
WE ARE NOT DEBATING DANCE MOVES
ON TIKTOK.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
HUMAN LIVES.
DR. FAUCI GAVE A LOT OF U.S.
TAXPAYER MONEY TO THE WUHAN LAB
FOR CHINESE SCIENTISTS TO
RESEARCH BAT CORONAVIRUSES.
NEITHER DR. FAUCI NOR ANY OF HIS
PEOPLE CAN GUARANTEE US THAT THE
CHINESE SCIENTISTS DIDN'T USE
THAT MONEY TO DO GAIN OF
FUNCTION AND TURN A NORMAL VIRUS
INTO A SUPER CHARGED VIRUS.
THEY WERE NOT MONITORED.
DR. FAUCI'S PEOPLE DID NOT
MONITOR THE LAB.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT HASN'T HAPPENED
BEFORE.
SINCE 1992, THERE HAVE BEEN 11
DIFFERENT EXPERIMENTS WIDELY
REPORTED IN IN WHICH SCIENTISTS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD HAVE TAKEN
A NORMAL VIRUS AND TURNED IT
INTO A SUPER CHARGED VIRUS.
NUMBER 2, THE VOW OF SECURITY IN
TERMS OF THE LAB LEAK AT THE
WUHAN LAB SUCKED.
CHINESE HAS A HISTORY OF LAB
LEAKS.
2004 AND 2019.
ALSO.
SINCE DAY 1, DR. FAUCI AND HIS
EXPERT FRIENDS HAVE TOLD US,
LOOK, THE VIRUS OCCURRED
NATURALLY.
IT JUMPED FROM A BAT TO A HOST
AND THEN TO HUMAN BEINGS.
WELL, IT'S BEEN A YEAR.
WHERE IS THE PROOF?
WHERE IS THE SMOKING BAT?
DO YOU REALLY THINK IF CHINA
COULD PROVE THIS VIRUS OCCURRED
NATURALLY IN NATURE IT WOULD
WITHHOLD THAT EVIDENCE?
NO IT WOULD SCREAM IT FROM THE
ROOFTOP.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE ABOUT
A BERKELEY PROFESSOR WHO SAID IF
YOU TAKE THE FINGERPRINT FROM
THE GENOME CHANGE THAT TURNED
THE BAT CORONAVIRUS VIRUS INTO
THE SUPER CHARGED COVID-19
VIRUS, AND COMPARED THAT
FINGERPRINT TO THE FINGERPRINTS
OF THE 11 SUPER CHARGED VIRUSS
THAT I JUST TALKED ABOUT THAT
WERE CREATED SINCE 1992, IT'S
THE SAME FINGERPRINT!
MAYBE COINCIDENCE?
BUT DR. FAUCI NEEDS TO ADDRESS
IT.
HE NEEDS TO HIT THESE THINGS
HEAD ON.
OTHERWISE, IT'S GOING TO
UNDERMINE PUBLIC HEALTH.
PEOPLE'S CONFIDENCE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO END UP TRUSTING DR.
PEPPER MORE THAN DR. FAUCI.
>> Sean: I THINK THAT'S THE LINE
OF THE NIGHT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TOP.
IT I AGREE WITH YOU.
HOW SAD WE LEARNED FROM THE
CLEVELAND CLINIC NO POINT
VACCINATING THOSE WHO HAVE
COVID-19.
YOU DON'T GET ANY ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT FROM VACUATIONS.
-- VACCINATIONS.
HE DIDN'T LISTEN TO THAT
SCIENCE.
YOU ARE DOING A GR